and joining us now is president biden's
national security advisor jake sullivan
uh jake good morning to you glad to have
you on this morning
i want to begin with a real-time picture
if you could provide it for us of the
situation at the airport in afghanistan
we understand the embassy drawdown is
complete how many more americans still
need to get out
so first i do want to salute the skill
and professionalism of our military
forces in afghanistan who did complete a
successful and safe drawdown of our
embassy our embassy is now closed and
our diplomatic president is presence is
secure at the kabul airport now our
military is working to secure that
airfield
as civilians desperate civilians are
going there seeking to get out
to secure it so that we can run a series
of evacuation flights for american
citizens who are in kabul
four afghans who have worked for us in
the past and for other vulnerable
afghans and we intend to carry out those
evacuation flights after securing the
airport over the coming days are we
talking dozens of americans hundreds of
americans can you put a rough number on
it i would say that in the end we want
to be moving thousands of people in
total
that includes a significant number of
americans
we are still doing outreach to
uh establish the total number of
americans in country it's important to
note that for weeks now we have been
communicating with americans telling
them to leave the country offering them
loans or financing so that they could
secure plane tickets if they didn't have
means to do so otherwise so we have
actually been working to evacuate
thousands and thousands of americans
over time now it's about determining who
is left
and who didn't heed those warnings along
the way jake we are looking at these
unbelievable pictures of people
literally hanging onto the plane as it's
taxing down the runway what do you have
to say about that what are your thoughts
when you see that
well
every time you're involved in policy
whether it's big or small you have to
remember it's about the human costs and
there are real human costs here and
seeing that image i recognize that and
it's heartbreaking but i also think
about the human cost of the alternative
which was president biden ordering u.s
forces to remain in afghanistan and that
would have required adding thousands and
thousands more u.s troops in the face of
a taliban onslaught
taking casualties and frankly having to
step up and fight for an afghan army
that was not to prepare to fight for
itself president biden was not prepared
to usher in a third decade of war and
put u.s troops in harm's way fighting
and dying to try to hold afghanistan
together when its own armed forces would
not fight to hold it together so this is
about hard choices and the choice he
made he believes was in the national
security interest of the united states
and we have uh executed a drawdown of
u.s forces in afghanistan and are now
conducting those evacuations but jake on
this question of preparedness it would
appear that the administration was not
prepared for kabul to fall this quickly
and for the taliban to overrun the
country this quickly how did you get it
so wrong and and you've been in two
administrations at this point advising
presidents on afghanistan when did you
personally realize that the afghan army
was just not up to this fight
well so first
we always knew uh were clear-eyed about
the distinct possibility that kabul
would eventually fall to the taliban it
was not an inevitability it was a
possibility the speed was at the very
fast end it was
not something we expected to go that
quickly but we had contingency plans in
place for any eventuality including a
quick fall of kabul those forces who are
at the airport right now did not appear
out of nowhere president biden
pre-positioned them
weeks ago in theater to be able to fly
them in in the event that kabul fell
very quickly we've secured the airport
we've secured our embassy and we've done
so in an extreme contingency knowing
before this went down that we had to be
prepared to do that jake now we had
hoped that they would fight we had hoped
that they would stand up but it became
clear as city after city fell that in
fact the afghan army was not prepared
despite billions of dollars and years of
training and all of the advanced
capabilities we provided and that raises
real questions about whether one more
year or two more years or five more
years would have made any difference in
terms of u.s troops staying in effort
given how quickly the taliban have taken
the country are you sure you can hold
the airport long enough to get all the
people out you need to
we've made very clear to the taliban
that if they disrupt our operations if
they menace or attack our forces that
there will be a severe and devastating
response we intend to secure the airport
we intend to move through these
evacuations and then we intend to
complete the retrograde this is not
without risk when is the president going
to address the country on this
everybody's waiting to hear from him
well the president has been uh deeply
engaged hour by hour in working through
this contingency we see that but we
haven't heard from him jake in the short
time we have left can you tell us when
he's going to speak to us about it i
think you can expect him to speak to the
country soon he hasn't put a definitive
time on it i won't get ahead of our
press team in terms of announcing that
but in the meantime what he's going to
do is stay laser focused on the task at
hand with his national security team
that's what he's been doing okay jake
sullivan from the white house thank you
very much